hello everybody and welcome back or not
welcome back but welcome to a brand new
let's play of followed by death chapter
1 this is an amnesia custom story it's
been a while since I played amnesia so
it's one that was recommended to me on
my Facebook page I do up regular polls
if you don't know on my Facebook page
about um what game I should play so I
like to communicate with my audience so
if you ever need if you ever want to see
you or chip in on what game I should
play go to my facebook page you'll see a
poll there every once in a while like
every so often ah followed by death
chapter 1 by JM f storm life has its own
way of making life has its own ways of
making the one deadly thing haunt you
for the rest of your life but at the
same time you have your own destination
to fulfill before that one deadly thing
finally gets to you and ends it all like
the darkness ah let's do it I'm guy
excited because this one is like
extremely highly reviewed better than la
caza an abduction 27th of february 1813
I was a farmer in Hastings all year my
wife and I lived in this nice form house
we had in the woods of the large forest
near our farmland during this one night
I woke up to the sound of my wife crying
it took me a little time to realize the
voices I heard we're not from the
nightmares I had ah if it was from
downstairs
I heard hair crying I went there to take
a look one what no I don't wanna
I heard a monster haha that guy did not
sound scared enough to do this he sounds
like he's from Finland because he sounds
like the guys from aj gaming the guy do
the dead dead island club with me huh
what can i turn oh it's a doily I'm
coming baby
slowly but surely huh I forgot what it
was like haha hey it no no sorry minute
let go through the door okay okay okay
outside
ah what my wife is dead now Oh [ __ ] I
ran away I was scared I was scared you
sound scared at that point I knew my
life from now on
changing away it had never been before
Oh God's been along to have say played
in media I forgot that it was the game
is longer hurt the beasts voice behind
me I saw the old Harmons castle from ok
that's not good
I broke stories with its legendary Fame
doubt about its ancient cup and it's
stiffed if Iowa they treat unwelcome
guests huh I never had two free things
on the ark that I would spend the worst
times of my life
it's frightening and terrifying dungeon
areas oh boy this is how it all started
okay oh yeah yeah
nice they got just not really
appropriate music but hey whatever
scariest part of my life we knew later
in that same day uh I woke up in a warm
and comforting place but I apparently
had passed out and didn't remember fate
someone had trapped me in here from the
looks of the place
my best guess was that I was inside the
castle
Ian okay still didn't quite understand
what was the meaning of that monster
that attacked the earlier on the same
day Oh now is the time to find answers
what about mourning your wife yet douche
bag chair Oh return to the chair boom
yeah don't need you right now - oh yeah
- the good old stuff
the libri rar e-book rare libri look
can't see a thing it's so dark
alright tender box alright why are we
going what are we doing hmm and it will
be nice to have things save
automatically for me chair ma come on
thank you with me old rustic wooden
chair be right back okay anything
anything nope I found you lying down in
our front yard so I brought you inside I
didn't find any serious damage in you so
you should be okay it's checking inside
him
when can you wink if I'm not here when
you wake up I might be somewhere in the
quarters area you add some luck this
time
our master Frances Harmon would not be
happy if he heard that I brought an
outsider in the castle but he's been
missing for over two weeks now please
come find me Joseph haha Joseph okay
I'll find you Joey Joey is Australian
for kangaroo or something I don't know
more science lessons with market flair
it locked it is locked nope nothing
all right I'm stealing all your stuff by
the way guy thanks for your hospitality
just throwing around everything messing
up your chairs alright
looking at each Cheers these are my
favorite type of chairs they're so
sturdy banca I cannot see a thing I see
nothing in here you all probably can't
see anything either ah where are we on
I can't run yet all broke your [ __ ] what
are you gonna do about it none wall yeah
here yeah give me that give me that give
me that nothing anything in here come on
monster closet
no nothing quarters I let me give a
quarter it's a mannequin the castle
seems to be really Pleasant scene to
live in but it's abandoned
hopefully Joe's there I love Joe already
I can tell he's gonna be a real great
guy
hello oh that's it that's a new painting
of Nursing that one before the music
starts oh no no not Alexander no no I
refuse a book I'll get you a book just
once a second let's see why wouldn't the
guy why wouldn't Joe leave a note in the
room where I was cuz there's a chance I
could have missed it
they are the ancient creatures of the
Damned they follow the ambition to steal
an innocent soul to progress in life he
said that a living creature that
sacrifices his or her soul to the great
earth for ultimate power becomes damned
and lost in the darkness forever after
days in their hatred of armed of mine
they devour the curse they devour the
luck hers inside them and become the
gatherer grasping for death and pain but
that is not true we have found the way
to get over it and continue life without
negative consequences we need to study
the great curse more to uncover the
ultimate secret whose
since no one has ever realized to be
true David you're not Daniel you're not
a murdering bastard or are you I don't
know I don't know enough to judge Wham
Brooke your [ __ ] here's your book throw
it in the fire miss but oh well
what's this more you take that
hospitality mob but do me good song oh
good job oh good job
writer Richard Harmon that is not
Richard hammer that is Alexander is not
your liar oh it's dark I'm not going in
that ed locked oh no I don't have do I
have a lantern I don't have a lantern
hey dark ah hello fire I don't fire how
you doing fire come here
I'll let you I'm burning your books do
you feel about that
how do you feel about that all right
what are we going
hello No what's this in the fire wonk
get in there get in the fire there you
go
burn it up yeah no I need some music
going on okay what was I supposed to do
Oh in here got dark dark dark dark dark
come on light it like that there we go
oh so much brighter at least it's not in
like at other mods in the dark like
super dark that's all that always
remember that we hold the cellar spare
key in the storage room here in the
quarters if you need us you'll find us
it usually at the cellar why would you
lock the cellar behind you Henry
why Henry why ah
huh got a chair loser loser
no one know ah ah come on oh oh it's so
creepy
alright I'm clearing my eyes you all
look at it ah ha ha Chuck for you ah
okay
ah no no mannequins huh wha ha ha no no
no no that's a no good
Graham there you go your head octopus
release Oh No kidding
thank you for Captain Obvious that's the
seller I'm guessing I need to find a
lantern it's won't budge why won't it
bunch a boo-boo get y'all walk by head
or caved in boom all right what's this
it won't bars the fancy door though I
don't think I've ever seen that door
before must be a new one
hello oh I see your candle hook tender
box ah I think in here
anyone boxes boxes but
hey what and nope nothing nothing it was
nothing the painting whoosh oh okay this
looks warm and vitamin close the door
behind me just in case
chairs woo these are fancy chairs punk
that's redlining
oh nothing special who's that who's that
y'all heard that right
you all heard that guy's dark dark dark
dark candle come on I'm actually gonna
use my tinderboxes this time but they
keep giving me one every time I need to
use one I'm not going to end another
amnesia game with 10 kajillion extra
candles I promise
now all right probably don't promise Oh
storage that's where I need to go but
let's check here first
haha take that all right no no no oh
that's the other side of that door hey
why won't it budge that is budging gosh
so stupid all right let's see
Oh smash mash magic magic stamp there we
go oh it's a bird dead bird okay
how's nothing waste of time ah dark
candle
Gabriel King the box where's this
so-called key there's it is theirs it is
alright nothing nothing nothing
not a wha nope no oh those nothing ah
huh huh ah ah pourquoi ah no no no no no
ha ha beat you I'm not alone in this
castle the monsters have followed me all
the way here oh that doesn't sound good
I got a rock
I got rocks I know I know it's dark
I want a lantern please my viewers can't
see anything
ah the Turk
ah ah poop ah what happened what
happened holes it pass out o clock again
I always forget to set my alarm for pass
out o clock okay oh what's this oh I
have cried so many times I used to hate
our little group including myself for so
long time
but now I have become numb from the
inside and I don't care anymore
uh I'm not gonna criticize him I think
these guys are from Finland they sounded
like a.j gave me some kissing different
Finland or some hmm
ah why my sanity dangerously low
Oh what the hell happened ah nope
hello ah Lantern Lantern aha but I need
to be sparing in let's use in the box
all right well that's actually gonna do
it for the first episode so thank you
all so much for watching I hope you
enjoy this let's play it's it's really
well made and they actually have decent
voice actors so I'm surprised and you've
got me yeah I'm a good boy sick lot
anyway thank you again so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye bye